Rob Greene thank you so much for joining
me today my pleasure
Rob as a teacher what what kind of
things do you teach about in history
prior to this current situation what was
the course like in Quebec well I will
say that there was a many of the
problems that we we've been voicing our
concerns about with the new curriculum
many of those same problems existed in
the old curriculum so the last
curriculum was very much focused on the
the story of the Quebec nation as
opposed to the story of Quebec Society
however I will say particularly with the
the depictions of immigrant communities
to Quebec we saw a lot more in the old
curriculum than we're seeing in the new
curriculum now this curriculum was
developed by the parti québécois when
they were empowered briefly and we we
know that the parti québécois is a
separatist independent east they want to
Quebec to separate from Canada yeah who
prepared this course well the the PQ
launched this curriculum reform in the
normal way that curriculum reform is
done in Quebec and that began with a
committee of experts that had very
diverse representation however soon
after the the first couple meetings of
that more diverse committee happened
they essentially turned the curriculum
reform process over to a conservative
sovereigntist lobby group called la
coalition post-war a group that for the
last 20 years has been sort of banging
the drums in the media about the D
nationalization of Quebec history and
which is absurd because I just I just
told you like the old history curriculum
probably I didn't have them there's
haven't been a history curriculum in
Quebec that's had more references to the
Quebec nation so it's it is sort of an
absurd charge that they've been making
and literally the the curriculum reform
process was basically handed to them
these are very nationalists historians
who wrote it exactly and they're and
they're they're a group that's funded by
basically the most conservative elements
in the nationalist movement now what are
your concerns not as I understand it
when this was introduced
English teachers in Montreal and Quebec
were saying whoa this is beyond the pale
there's there are many many problems
with this history it is - it is very
nationalist it leaves out a lot of
actual history to promote a separatist
agenda yeah and and there was complaints
about that what happened well I should
actually say that initially teachers
were very supportive of this reform
because ostensibly it was being done for
reasons that had to do with the
structure of the program so it used to
be that year one of the program you'd
have the whole history of Quebec in
Canada and then year two you'd speed
through that whole history four times
focused on different themes and this was
very cumbersome for students so the
extensible reason for this reform was to
change the structure to make it more
like other history programs you know
half the history in year one and the
other half in year two however along the
way it's the cot it really became about
content as well and that's where both
teachers in the Anglophone sector but
also First Nations groups and and Inuit
groups began to speak up about what they
were seeing in that content and that was
basically you know the elimination of
Quebec semuc diversity we see no
reference to immigrant communities we
see the the recommendations of the Truth
and Reconciliation Commission had been
sort of ignored and Anglophones were
sort of presented as in the historical
narrative in the role of comic book
villains we're sort of presented as a
monolithic group of elites that are
there to sort of impede the progress of
Quebec at every turn and so it was all
of those issues that I think you know a
variety of different people started to
to raise awareness about now the
interesting thing of course is that the
separatist government introduced this
and there were complaints about it and
now we have since then a new government
supposedly a federalist leaning
government yeah who heard these
complaints I said we will correct them
and what has to be there well you know
that's the million dollar question at
you know we this has been
what has been so baffling about this and
you know theories range from just
straight-up government incompetence that
they didn't realize this reform process
that they inherited was underway and
just kind of let it continue until it
was sort of too late people are also
thinking maybe it's because they had
sent the textbooks to print before that
first wave of criticism last year and so
this is a money question yeah it could
be a money it could be a money question
but I know there's also the issue of how
sincere they were about making changes
so last week a press release was put out
by the Katta Vick school board basically
saying that the most recent round of
consultation of indigenous communities
that happened was a was a farce that and
and even worse than that
it was repeating colonial patterns of
the government dealing with indigenous
people that that really really need to
finally come to an end so in the history
that you are obliged to teach your
students if I'm understanding this
correctly leaves out almost entirely the
indigenous aspect of of Quebec and
Canada and and the Anglophone community
are treated sort of as you say villains
or disdainfully and impeding the
progress of yeah and there's there you
know in the first draft of the
curriculum there was not a single
reference to a positive contribution to
Quebec society by an Anglophone actor or
person in the in the revised draft there
is a single reference to a positive
contribution it does acknowledge that
Anglophones were active in the early
days of Quebec feminist movement but you
know to me the the really big omission
here is the Irish because the Irish were
Montreal's original working class they
were involved in some of the early labor
struggles they were a part of even you
know that that working-class history is
even part of the the early history of
the montreal canadiens that is a you
know very important in this city and in
this in this province so so to leave
that the Irish out of the picture
is really problematic America though I
mean as a history teacher when you talk
about Montreal which was at one time a
the single most important city in Canada
up until say the 1960s we had a city did
we I mean who built the city in that
sense as a modern city was it not the
Scottish and they may be ethically you
know McGill University and all the
hospitals no these are donated and so on
so forth I mean as as an Anglophone and
a historian yeah how do you feel about
this I mean well I you know I feel I
feel that that history is being hijacked
by a political agenda and and I want to
be clear that you know when I've been
criticizing the curriculum I'm not
saying that I want to replace one
ideologically driven narrative with
another I don't I'm not looking to
replace a sovereign as narrative with a
federalist narrative I'm looking for
students to be exposed to the range of
different perspectives that have existed
in Quebec society over the years because
it's only by exposing them to a range of
perspectives that they can develop
critical thinking skills and that's what
that's what a history course is is
supposed to be about so you know even
though you know I am an Anglophone
teaching in an English school board I
see one of my biggest roles as an
English an Anglophone teacher is to help
my Anglophone students understand the
perspectives of the francophone majority
and it's only that's how we can start to
build social cohesion and sort of break
down the notion of the two solitudes but
again if if you're teaching Anglophones
and want to teach them and expanded it
and I don't know if I should use work
more truthful he's very are what's
happening with the francophones who are
the majority are they being will shall I
use the word propagandized that's that
is that is the worry right like I'm I'm
actually not so concerned about that
like the history teachers that I know in
the English Montreal school board for
example they're they're excellent
teachers and they are going to be
supplementing the curriculum in a way
that does justice for their students but
as you as you point out the problem is
what about students up in lacks Asia or
what about even students meaning
a system whose teacher found out they
were teaching the program five days you
know before they started who doesn't
have the time to be preparing the the
supplemental material well I'm a
colleague of mine had a child in school
and that person said when the child went
to the history class the teacher said
here's the official thing the history
that you need for the test so learn that
yeah but here's the test of history that
I'm going to teach you which is very I
mean wow what message is that sending
then that and that's this is really part
of the problem for me as a teacher is
that there's all sorts of research out
there about how effective pedagogy
involves creating materials in which
students can see themselves reflected in
one way or another and when students
don't see and so when I think just my
school West not high it's a
multicultural school in downtown
Montreal this new curriculum is
rendering many of my students invisible
and sort of demonizing another group of
them so where do they see themselves
reflected they don't and that what that
does is that makes my job as a teacher
trying to get them to pass a
standardized test that much harder let
alone trying to get them to develop a
love of history okay you know which
which ultimately should is should be my
most important priority but because of
these ministry exams I sometimes have to
focus on getting them through that is
there a problem in Canada in the fact
that we don't have a countrywide history
agenda but it's controlled by the
provinces well I mean there is there's a
lot of justification to that just for
example you know I think you know
Canada's history is vast and I think it
is it does make sense for example that
that British Columbia's history
curriculum would be focused on some
different things but I well I see it
maybe in another way that I think it's
problematic in any public education
system in a democratic society that that
people that are part of that society are
being eliminated from the
Oracle narrative I just think is the
role of public education should be about
helping us understand each other
building social cohesion helping
understand helping students better
understand and think critically about
the society in which they live what's
the solution Rob Green I mean your group
is asking for changes yeah what's what's
going to happen what do you think what
happened we've we've launched an online
petition and we've gotten a lot of
signatures already the and we like thus
far the the efforts that we've made in
speaking out I think they have had an
impact like there have been some changes
that have been made but I think it's
going to take more so you know whether
this so basically what we've demanded of
government in our petition is sort of
two things in the short term to
immediately work with school boards and
other stakeholders to develop
supplemental materials to immediately
supplement what's there because we
realize the government isn't going to
overnight produce new textbooks and have
a whole new program so we've got a short
term goal that's sort of the you know a
band-aid solution but then the long term
solution is extensive public
consultations of all the various
communities to make sure that this is
being done right because again when you
know reading about the the consultations
that weren't consultations of indigenous
communities this is this is awful this
is the opposite direction that we should
be going and particularly in light of
the recommendations of the Truth and
Reconciliation Commission I mean one of
one of those recommendations is that
every provincial Minister of Education
should have an expert in indigenous
history as sort of an assistant to them
and to my knowledge that does not happen
in Quebec and it needs to happen and had
it happened we would not be seeing some
of the problems in the curriculum that
we see now Rob green thank you very much
for coming in today
great pleasure